[Musique]
bfm politique avec hedwige chevrillon
david book on est notre invité bruno
retailleau sénateur de vendée président
du groupe l'est républicain au sénat
merci d'être avec nous ce midi je
voudrais commencer évidemment avec ses
images de violence dont philippe gaudin
vient de parler que l'on a vu un peu
partout en marge de la manifestation
contre la proposition de loi sécurité
globale vous avez twitté hier soir
pendant combien de semaines je vous cite
encore emmanuel macouin son ministre de
l'intérieur vont ils regardaient
impuissants 400 casseurs mettre le feu
dans les rues de paris
ils veulent tuer des flics dans le
message suivant vous dites ces images
nous font honte
il ya un an en pleine mobilisation
contre les fraudes et gilet jaune vous
aviez proposé un texte
noah anticasseurs l'avait été résumée
comme ça on partie jugée
anticonstitutionnelle
pourquoi ce que si compliqué de lutter
contre ce phénomène
d'abord je veux dire que c'est la
chienlit et que la chienlit ça suffit et
que de week-end en week-end on voit bien
ce sont toujours les mêmes images des
commerces qui sont saccagés des
policiers des gendarmes qui sont
sauvagement agressé et des voitures qui
brûlent voilà et pendant ce temps là il
ya le risque d'une accoutumance
ça fait des années que j'ai observé ce
phénomène parce que j'étais président de
région pays de la loire et à nantes nous
avions très fréquemment le week-end ces
casseurs qui venait et qui s'était fait
la main avec notre dame des landes
je considère d'ailleurs que la faute
originelle des manuels maquereau en
matière de manquement à l'autorité c'est
d'avoir donné raison à ces casseurs à
ses black blocks sur notre dame des
landes où je permets de vous rappeler
que nous avions 200 décisions de justice
favorables et il y avait un référendum
favorable
alors oui j'avais ce ton d'avant si josi
parce que malheureusement dans ma région
j'avais observé ce phénomène qui est
totalement nouveau totalement nouveau on
a affaire à une organisation
paramilitaire de gens qui sont très très
bien entraînés et qui déjoue les
stratégies parfois un peu trop statique
des forces de l'ordre c'est nouveau en
partie dans l'apparition france mais le
phénomène n est pas du tout venant vous
avez règlement bien documenté avait
raison
mais en discutant avec des magistrats en
discutant avec les forces de l'ordre
j'avais proposé une loi anti black
blocks le fait qu' on puisse déjà dès
lors que quelqu'un dissimule son visage
dans une manifestation
évidemment ce n'est pas pour se protéger
des coups de soleil c'est pour éviter
qu'on ne le reconnaisse bien et j'avais
proposé qu' on puisse créer un nouveau
délit
ça a été fait c'était en partie censurée
par le conseil constitutionnel mais je
crois qu'il ya une autre étape
parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut les
attraper mais ils y apprennent de
judiciarisation c'est à dire que très
fréquemment on arrive mal le juge
judiciaire arrive mal à montrer et à
faire le lien entre l'identité mais
aussi la commission de ces actes qui
sont insupportables et moi je venais
d'intention endroit je propose je
propose puisqu'on voit bien ça devient
un phénomène récurrent qui menace
l'ordre républicain et les braves gens
je propose que l'on créé des brigades
débris d'actes anti black bloc parce que
il faut réussir sur une longue distance
à observer des caméras de vidéo
protection il faut observer des réseaux
sociaux si follistes un rayon des
policiers fassent des heures mais vous
le savez ça sera décortiqué des vidéos
je récuse via les bras vous savez on est
on est capable je veux rendre hommage
mois à nos forces de l'ordre qui sont en
première ligne
on le voit bien et sans doute que j'y
reviendrai pour condamner les propos du
président de la république lorsqu'il a
été interrogé par qu'est ce qu'elles ont
de 9 ce méga dont vous parlez ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce qu'elles ont de
neuf c'est que elle serait institué un
peu comme des brigades antiterroristes
leur fonction leur unique fonction ce
serait cette infiltration ses études des
images pour pouvoir prendre des
individus et les confondent pour que
l'on puisse avoir des incriminations qui
les mènerait directement en prison par
exemple par exemple l'incrimination
d'association de malfaiteurs par exemple
de bande organisée si on ne tape pas dur
et fort on se condamne à l'impuissance
est et ce qui est terrible c'est que
vous verrez aujourd'hui demain cette
semaine le ministre d'intérieur
peut-être le prison dorée public avec
des coups de menton des discours
martiaux et vous aurez samedi prochain
un samedi ordinaire c'est-à-dire à
nouveau ces images que ne supportent
plus les français
la chienlit le désordre ça suffit
bonjour bruno retailleau
vous apportez finalement une double
réponse à la fois législatives et
technique est ce qui est un sujet de
commandement est-ce que ce que nous
constatons tous les samedis ou presque
dans la capitale est aussi la
responsabilité du préfet de police de
paris monsieur l'allemand est ce qu'à
vos yeux
il fait un bon boulot ou bien est-ce
qu'au contraire il est un petit peu à
mettre en cause dans cette affaire
moi c'est pas mon problème d'abord
monsieur l'allemand agi sous la
responsabilité sous les ordres du
ministre de l'intérieur et de son
cabinet donc moi je veux pas condamner
les lampistes
simplement je me borne moi puisque je
suis législateur d'abord je propose je
propose toujours quand j'ai mais une
critique elle est toujours suivie d'une
proposition
il faut être positif je pense c'est ce
que j'essaie de faire et je suis
législateur dont quand la loi ne
convient pas je fais voter je propose
une nouvelle loi c'est ce que j'ai fait
avec la loi anti black bloc mais
désormais il faut que la hiérarchie
effectivement il faut que le ministre
puisse passer au degré supérieur
on ne va pas me dire on a des services
qui déjoue des dizaines et des dizaines
d'attentats terroristes
donc on peut si on y met les moyens
voilà que je propose
on peut neutraliser ces individus
aujourd'hui il ya un risque c'est que
l'ordre républicain
chaque week-end il est trop élevé et
donc on ne peut plus supporter
d'ailleurs les français ne l'admettent
+1 bruno retailleau bonjour les forces
de l'ordre sont en première ligne et
vous l'avez dit le président de la
république a donné une interview à as
brut dans lequel il disait il a reconnu
l'existence de policiers du sit a qui
sont violents et qu'il faut sanctionner
il a dit j'ai pas de problème à parler
de violences policières
mais je le déconstruit c'est devenu un
slogan je suis toujours pour des gens
qui ont un projet politique vous avez
l'air de condamner vous venez de dire
les propos en tous les cas du présent la
république en quoi en quoi ils vous
choque ce sont pas ces propos uniquement
qui m'ont choqué si je pense puisque il
ya eu la mort du président valéry
giscard d'estaing saly un an du
président jacques chirac et à chaque
fois on est revenu sur l'histoire et on
a été tenté de leur a collé des
adjectifs pour qualifier leur le
septennat leur quinquennat
on a dit par exemple jacques chirac
proche des français
on a dit giscard d'estaing modernisateur
je pense que ce qui restera de la
présidence des mails macron c'est le
désordre et la discorde ce désordre et
la discorde viennent d'une chose on a vu
d'ailleurs en jeu dans cet entretien
brut mais qu'on voit en jeu depuis
quelques années depuis le début de son
quinquennat
c'est sa capacité à s'adapter au public
qu'il a et un instant où lui parler
choisi les monts en fonction du public
ce qui laisse à penser finalement qu'il
ya une forme d'assas hérité par exemple
et là je le condamne quand il dit quand
il sous-entend que les policiers ferait
du contrôle au faciès
c'est extrêmement grave parce que c'est
asséné cette affirmation fausse qu' il y
aurait un racisme systémique dans la
police n'ont alors fait un raccourci à
bruno retailleau le président de la
république s est prêt si justement sur
ce passage est ce que vous contestez
vous l'existence de contrôle au faciès
dans nos rues dans nos villes moi je
contiens ne disent toutes les dérives
toutes les dérives individuelles je ne
parle jamais de violence policière il ya
un autre point de mire le lion gaz il ya
des contrôles au faciès en france
eh bien j'espère que non et si c'est le
cas il faut les condamner les policiers
e mail le reconnaissent mais bien
souvent il dispose de moi je ne veux
signalement de signalement d'un individu
qu'ils recherchent et dont qu'ils
appliquent c'est donc à l'offensive mais
c'est comme si vous me disiez tient à
quelqu'un était dénoncé parce qu'il
avait un pardessus blanc il faut
absolument reconnaître cet individu ou
qui roule dans une voiture rouge bon ça
c'est autre chose
la systématisation de contrôle facile
c'est toi quelque chose de différent
c'est que on accroche cette idée d'une
couleur de peau à une délinquance
systématique
non il ya un autre point sur lequel les
propos m'a choqué c'est lorsque le
président de la république dit
finalement il faut trouver 3 500 noms
l'origine africaine ultramarines ou
maghrébine pour les mettre en valeur
dans l'espace public en est je pense que
c'est du communautarisme je pense que
quand on est français attachés au modèle
français ont choisi des non pas par leur
couleur de peau qu'ils soient blancs qui
soit jaune qu'ils soient noirs peu
importe on les choisit pour l'exemple
est-ce que la couleur
importante les cas il ya très peu y a
que des blancs non mais parce que c'est
lui parce que parce qu'il ya notre essor
mais il ya aussi mais il ya eu aussi
bien sûr dans notre histoire des gens
qui portaient cave une autre couleur de
peau mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
si on veut s'adresser à des communautés
noires maghrébine blanche jaune demain
et leur proposer leur propre héros alors
alors on déconstruit l'histoire
nationale non exclusive renault royaume
une otarie un peu le monde à l'envers
excusez moi on peut dire aussi la
république c'est la même pour tous et il
n'y a pas de raison que les hommes et
les femmes qui sont mises en valeur est
une seule couleur de peau c'est ce que
je pense que vous avez dit il n'y a pas
que c'est ce que je me lance dans notre
histoire ce que je vous dis absolument
ce que je vous dis c'est simplement en
d'autres termes l'article numéro 1 de
notre constitution de la vème république
qui reconnaît des citoyens sans
distinction d'origine de race ou de
religion et je suis attaché à cela et je
ne voulais pas que le raidillon je ne
veux pas que le président de la
république pour apaiser tel ou tel
groupe de telle ou telle communauté
puisse dire il va y avoir des héros qui
vont correspondre à telle communauté et
d'autres héros qui vont correspondre à
d'autres communautés cela c'est le
modèle anglo américains comme disait
d'ailleurs de lui régis debray il avait
appelé le gallo ricains et vous oubliez
l essayer de marier américain et gallo
gallois bruno riou gaulois vous oubliez
toute une partie du raisonnement qui est
de dire il ya une reconnaissance qui
manquent
il ya un travail de mémoire qui n'a pas
été fait sur tout
toute une série de deux d'événements de
notre histoire en particulier liées à la
colonisation
et c'est vers cela que le président de
la république veut pas laisser ce qu'on
comprend de son intervention récente ça
vous pour vous c'est a balayé d'un
revers de la main
il ne fait pas en occuper david quand je
suis un passionné d'histoire et je crois
comme vous et comme beaucoup d'autres
français que toutes les grandes
histoires des grandes nations
mail des heures de gloire des oeuvres
lumineuses et des heurts sont ça j'en
suis convaincu quand j'avais entendu le
président de la république accusé la
france du pire des crimes
souvenez-vous en alu la colonisation
commettent un crime contre l'humanité le
pire de tout ce que je dis c'est que on
a en france 2
à part de quelques élites un sport qui
consiste à débiner la france comme avait
dit un jour jean pierre chevènement à
rendre la france coupable éternellement
coupable cette espèce de vision lacrymal
pénitentielle de notre histoire et je
vais vous dire pourquoi cette pose un
problème ne peut pas être quand je dis
que non plus c'est ce que j'ai toujours
c'est ce que j'ai dit mais quand même le
crime contre l'humanité le crime contre
l'humanité vous voyez à quoi cela
renvoie et quand vous le faites vous
envoyer un message à ses jeunes ils sont
sur la voie du séparatisme de la
sécession si vous dites que la france
est détestable
comment voulez vous faire aimer la
france à ces jeunes là voilà ce que je
dis mais que cette cette dérive qui
consiste à dire que la france est
d'abord coupable pour que avant il faut
la reconnaître aimable c'est terrible ça
créé une fracture qui est une fracture
profonde et si on veut finalement
associé ces jeunes générations à anono
collectif
je voudrais qu'on a qu'on avance si vous
le voulez bien la proposition de loi sur
la sécurité globale qui était en
discussion qui est accapare beaucoup de
débats politiques et notamment le sénat
en ce moment est-ce qu'elle va dans
votre sens est ce qu'elle est utile sans
rentrer forcément dans la polémique
autour de l'article dany taristas est ce
que pour vous il fallait une loi
supplémentaire où tout est déjà là
c'est toujours le même problème je pense
que globalement et souvent en france on
a beaucoup de lois vous savez que les
chinois écrivent le mot france avec un
idéogramme qui signifie le pays des lois
et montaigne à plusieurs siècles disait
que nous avions autant de lois que le
reste du monde donc c'est quelque chose
de culturel et je pense souvent que il
manque le courage d'appliquer les lois
existantes mais parfois il ya des trous
dans la raquette
il ya sans doute un trou dans la
raquette pourquoi parce que depuis
quelques années les collectivités
locales sont devenus adultes notamment
les communes les maires on l'a vu
d'ailleurs à nice s'il n'y avait pas eu
ce policier municipal armés je pense que
la tuerie n'aurait pas été aussi vite
arrêté donc il ya ce qu'on appelle un
continuant de sécurité et à ce titre là
elle est intéressant alors simplement
elle lui répond que partiellement parce
que le problème de l'insécurité en
france ne concerne pas que le strict
problème de la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre ça concerne aussi la réponse
pénale qui est trop molle et je
considère que depuis madame taubira en
passant par maints belloubet jusqu'à
monsieur dupont moretti
cette réponse pénale elle est absolument
trop molle
il faut une révolution pénalties demain
si demain on veut apporter plus de
sécurité aux français c'est à dire des
peines construire des prisons alors que
ce sont des milliers de détenus que on a
libéré et on continue à le faire et il
faut comme par exemple aux pays bas
avoir des peines de prison courte
construits dans des prisons qui sont pas
les prisons qu'on connaît mais dans des
centres de courtes peines
il faut que d'ailleurs qui a un délit
une infraction et une tête et qu'elle
souhaite exécuter en france des dizaines
de milliers de peine vous le savez ne
sont pas exécutées et faut une
révolution aussi de la profession
pourquoi parce que elle est souvent que
le char disais donc et des moyens à
apporter mais surtout mais surtout il ya
des juges des magistrats qui rendent la
justice non pas au nom du peuple
français mais d'une idéologie on la
nourrit travers les murs des cons et de
ce point de vue là la partialité
l'impartialité de la justice
c'est un point et au delà de la
dépendance c'est cette question de
l'impartialité qu'il faut autre texte
qui occupe les esprits en ce moment
c'est la loi visant à renforcer les
principes républicains la laïcité le
texte sera présenté mercredi en conseil
des ministres avant d'entamer son
processus législatif les sénateurs
républicains
votre groupe avait demandé une
modification de la constitution sur ce
sujet étaient refusés par l'assemblée
nationale
je voudrais qu'on essaie d'être le plus
clair possible le plus con si possible
aussi pour que ce soit clair pourquoi
et ça aurait changé quoi ça ça aurait
changé tout simplement beaucoup de
choses pour des juges pour des maires
pour des chefs d'établissements
scolaires pour des présidents
d'associations nous étions vous nous
voulions ancrer dans la constitution le
principe de laïcité en le développant
parce que le principe de la laïcité
il est connu sans doute de vous et de
nos auditeurs spectateurs comme étant la
contrainte qui s'impose à l'état la
neutralité
bon la neutralité vis-à-vis des cultes
et c'est l'état ne subventionne de
reconnaît on connaît la loi 1905
qu'est ce que c'est que la laïcité il ya
un devoir vis-à-vis des citoyens nul
citoyen nul groupe ne peut s'exonérer en
fonction de son origine en fonction de
la religion du respect de la règle
commune ça voulait dire ses doigts cette
phrase m dans les grès sûrement ça
voulait dire que cette phrase à elle est
importante parce qu'elle s'adresse par
exemple les hôpitaux
aucun aucune famille ne peut demander
par exemple à ce qu'une femme soit
commandé âge vu par un médecin femme
c'est aussi pour les piscines
la question des horaires nous voulions
absolument donner parce qu'aujourd'hui
la république allait défier la norme
suprême c'est la constitution et nous
voulions donner une assise extrêmement
solide dans notre constitution dans
cette norme suprême pour arrêter les
visées pourquoi les délais à rallonge à
l'islamiste pardon pourquoi les députés
ont-ils refusé mais parce qu'il ya une
forme d'ambiguïté notamment de la
majorité du président de république est
une majorité d'ailleurs plutôt à gauche
tu restes un mais mais je crois que
cette ambiguïté de sa majorité
c'est sa propre ambiguïté vous vous
rendez compte que il aura fallu attendre
pratiquement la dernière année du
quinquennat pour qu' on puisse avoir un
texte contre l'islamisme que compte des
normes même pas d'ailleurs comme tel il
a changé trois ou quatre fois deux
titres l'ambiance que le titre fait peur
l'ambiguïté à le président la république
a essayé de la levée lors du discours
des mureaux avec des propositions très
concrètes et parfois assez radicales
comme par exemple l'interdiction de
l'école à domicile l'an le projet de loi
séparatisme qui arrivera à mercredi en
conseil des ministres il ya cette notion
l'idée de dire la scolarisation la
scolarisation venir on est obligé
d'aller à l'école physiquement à partir
de 3 ans il ya cinquante mille enfants
en france qui sont concernés par par
l'école à domicile les parents se
mobilisent en disant là nous on est
victime collatérale en gros de la lutte
contre l'islamisme
quelle est votre position là dessus
bruno retailleau je ne voterai pas cet
article
comme je les ai vus rédigé peut-être
va-t-il changer j'attends le texte qui
sera présenté en conseil des ministres
mercredi prochain
mais oui vous devez changer parce que
les conseillers d'état sont en train de
beaucoup travaillé là dessus je viens
danser demande je ne suis pas entré dans
la technique vous faites pour moi
facile pour les gens cette pédagogie ce
que je veux simplement dire
c'est que ce cet article là et
liberticide il ya quand même un paradoxe
que je ne m'explique pas mails mâcon se
présente sur la scène internationale
comme le héros comme le champion de la
défense de la liberté contre par exemple
les démocraties de l'est ou d'ailleurs
qui seraient des démocraties libérales
et que fait-il en france il menace la
liberté d'enseignement parce que
l'instruction à domicile est une
composante depuis 1882 la loi ferry est
une composante de la liberté
d'enseignement
il menace la liberté de culte on l'a vu
avec la fameuse jour jeu stupide de 30
personnes dans les églises comme dans
les chapelles comme dans les synagogues
ou les mosquées ils menacent aussi bien
sur la liberté de l'information
l'article 24 de la sécurité globale je
trouve que ça fait beaucoup je pense que
il ya à la fois une forme d'impuissance
mais cette impuissance ou souvent elle
appelle une autre forme d'autoritarisme
voilà c'est ce que je dénonce je pense
moi que tel qu'il est rédigé je pense
qu'il faut taper les islamistes qui
veulent enfermer les petites filles chez
eux pour évidemment les commandes et à
les contraindre
et comment dirais-je les intoxiquer
symétrie pas une bonne idée au dire en
france on va à l'école
non non mais la nouvelle école non bien
ce nom mais il ya c'est exactement nous
avons volé il ya un an et demi une loi
sur les écoles hors contrat on aurait
très bien pu dire on interdit n'est pas
leur contrat il ya des écoles hors
contrat les montées ce rite c'est parce
qu'il ya des enfants qui ont besoin
pédagogie différente et ça c'est
important
bon moi je suis attaché au principe de
liberté mais une liberté qui doit être
un régime d'autorisation contrôlait pas
c'est mon point de vue et je pense qu'au
sénat je ne serai pas le seul à le
porter on marque une courte pause nous
venons pour la suite de bfm politique
dans quelques secondes sur deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la suite de bfm politique c'est bruno
retailleau qui notre invité aujourd'hui
nous parlions de la du projet de loi
visant à renforcer les principes
républicains et la laïcité parmi les
propositions qui font débat bruno
retailleau il ya enfin des bas surtout
dans l'opposition il y à l'enseignement
de l'arabe à l'école publique pourquoi
est-ce que ça fait débat pas ça fait
débat parce que ça a new world ça me
heurte je pense que encore une fois pour
revenir à nos fondements à notre
constitution article 2 le français c'est
la langue de la république française
c'est tout et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
français pas toujours bien parlé et je
suis contre parce que ce n'est pas notre
modèle français c'est le modèle
américain une fois de plus mais le
modèle multiculturaliste et est un
modèle à mon avis multi conflictuelle il
va pas rentrer je pense que il faut ce
qu'on ait pas de problème pour l'espagne
pour le pour l'italie par exemple
non mais je veux que très franchement
vous d'abord on n'a pas du tout c'est
pas la même langue c'est pas le même
type de l'an mais je veux moi que le
français soit bien parler je pense que
déjà quand on parle bien une langue on
peut plus facilement passer à d'autres
l'ont voit là mais vous vous répondez
pas vraiment parce que en fait l'idée de
d'emmanuel macron c'est de dire cette
langue là si on la prend pas à l'école
de la république
beaucoup d enfants qui veulent la
prendre dans les parents veulent qu'ils
l'apprennent vont aller dans des écoles
justement où ils peuvent être confrontés
à l'islamisme oui mais je sais mais
justement malheureusement c'est aussi
ceux qu'utilisent les islamistes cette
langue véhiculaire de la fondamentalisme
religieux mais aussi politique il faut
combattre
voilà on n'a pas le même problème
évidemment les quitta lien avec le
l'anglais avec cet art voilà donc il
faut le reconnaître il faut l'assumer
faut le nommer
et il faut dire voilà nous on est
porteur de valeurs et fait valeur la
passe aussi par l'expression par les
mots par d'un vocabulaire par une
syntaxe voilà nous sommes patrie
littéraire comme disait quelqu'un et
notre littérature est écrit en langue
française nous rénovons tayeau vous
l'historien littéraire peut-elle
président de la république est ce que
vous iriez sur un média comme brut
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je pense que
c'est parce que j'ai contesté d'ailleurs
je trouve que il excelle d'ailleurs en
matière de communications les mâles
macron je pense que il ya des médias
qui sans y compris sur des réseaux
sociaux qui sont des médias qui sont
beaucoup plus vus par les jeunes et on
est entré c'est vrai dans une société où
c'est compliqué pour un homme politique
n'est pas une fragmentation de
l'audience vous en savez quelque chose
ici sur bfm et et chacun est un peu dans
sa caverne
chacun reçoit d'ailleurs les
informations qui sont présélectionnés
par des algorithmes et ces informations
que les gens reçoivent ils sont
présélectionnés pour aller dans leur
sens donc jeanne bien finalement est
confortée dans sa conviction et je pense
que c'est important d'aller précisément
vers les uns et les autres qu'elle n'en
soit leur âge je voudrais qu'on parle de
la porno mikovits 19 maintenant bruno
retailleau
hier il y avait les manifestations
d'opposition à la loi sécurité globale
mais les aussi pas mal de manifestation
des professionnels de la montagne la
neige tombe elle tombe parfois beaucoup
les stations sont ouvertes les remontées
mécaniques
elle reste fermée avec deux exceptions
toutefois pour les professionnels et les
enfants licenciés dans les clubs de ski
question simple faut-il rouvrir selon
vous ces remontées mécaniques
moi je pense que en prenant des
précautions on peut parfaitement un
moment ou un autre
dès lors que ces précautions sont prises
réouvrir les notamment les remonte
pentes enfin les remontées mécaniques
parce que on peut grâce à des mesures de
précaution des mesures sanitaires faire
en sorte que l'activité se poursuivent
d'autres pays d'ailleurs l'ont fait la
suisse
bien sûr mais pas seulement la suisse et
je pense que la france doit le faire moi
j'ai déjeuné avec les présidents de
groupes du sénat avec le président
république ça a été un sujet important
du déjeuner de mercredi dernier j'ai dit
au président de république
l'asie est en train d'être confronté à
une troisième vague
il est vraisemblable que au mois de
janvier la france soit confrontée à une
troisième
la seule façon de reprendre le contrôle
de l'épidémie est d'avoir une vraie
stratégie mais qui qui opère cette fois
ci alors il ya le vaccin mais dans les
trois prochains mois
le vaccin malheureusement n'arrêtera pas
l'épidémie dans les trois prochains mois
le vaccin ce sera deux millions trois
millions de personnes pas beaucoup plus
mais il faut tester vous savez qu'au
mois de novembre ces trois dernières
semaines sont des chiffres officiels
le dépistage le nombre de tests pcr a
été divisé par deux c'est une
préoccupation
moi je pense que il faut si on veut
reprendre le contrôle de l'épidémie si
on veut justement reprendre l'activité
aussi économie
il faut absolument tester amende
utilisant aussi des tests salivaires
voilà qui sont à peine autorisée on
aurait pu le faire avant vous savez ce
sont des tests pcr donc très fiable
kabylité 87 pour cent quarante minutes
le résultat donc il faut là aussi les
généraliser mais là encore on a un temps
de retard
mais surtout il faut dépister mais
ensuite il faut pouvoir tracer faire
comme les japonais essayer de détecter
le super contaminateur d'aller vers le
cas contacts et isolé ce qu'on ne ferait
pas pour le moment benoît tailleu ont
parlé des stations de ski les
restaurateurs on voit bien que les
restaurateurs ils sont à bout il on
parle ils n'ont pas de bain de boue du
tunnel on ne sait pas très bien
effectivement si à une troisième vague
qu'est ce qui peut se passer est ce que
vous dites quand même il faut les
rouvrir parce que c'est presque une
question de vie ou de mort pour eux moi
je pense que on devrait pouvoir les
rouvrir avant le 20 janvier prochain
avec un certain nombre de mesures avec
des purificateurs d'air en obligeant un
certain nombre évidemment par exemple de
mètres carrés par convive y compris avec
des séparations parfois mais si on ne
fait pas ça on va tous mourir guéri les
députés proposent le 4 janvier dernier l
air les députés de l'union fait la même
proposition à me va leucate en tout cas
anticipé par rapport aux 20 janvier je
pense que l'idée c'est que l'on risque
de devoir vivre malgré ce virus pendant
encore six mois c'est clair et on peut
pas faire une politique de stop and go
donc moi je suis pour rave réouvrir de
façon raisonnable l'activité mais en
étant intraitable sur la stratégie de
contrôle de l'épidémie
l' isolement on va d'ailleurs voté sans
doute demain lundi au sénat pour l'
isolement pour faire en sorte comme les
allemands que les français qui seront
isolés ne perdent rien de leur revenu on
va voter par exemple sur le jour de
carence vous avez quand vous avez un un
arrêt de travail un jour de carence vous
n'êtes pas payé et c'est là je pense que
on va voter
l'annulation ce jour de carence pour que
les gens qui seront isolés ne perdent
rien et les allemands sous contrainte je
suis contre l'isolément obligatoire je
suis pour un isolement qui soit
contrôlée par exemple comme dans des
pays il faut pouvoir appeler les gens il
faut pouvoir qui est ailleurs comme
a paris il ya une expérience avec
l'ap-hp qui est intéressant des équipes
qui suivent qui appellent par exemple
des sms mais aussi d appeler des appels
téléphoniques
il va falloir aller porter pour les
personnes isolées qui seront dans cet
isolement parce qu'elles sont cas
positifs d'un portage de repas donc ça
doit se travailler avec des équipes
mobiles 1 est en lien avec les
collectivités locales et non pas depuis
la bureaucratie parisienne bruno
retailleau le gouvernement a présenté
les grandes lignes de la stratégie de
vaccination à venir avec la nomination
notamment dans le hack s'en va pas
rentrer dans les détails pour l'instant
mais en eau personnes prioritaires plus
de 65 ans en ehpad les personnels
médicaux qui sont eux-mêmes à risque est
ce que c'est la bonne stratégie
le problème cette fois ci ce n'est pas
la stratégie c'est la déclinaison de la
stratégie parce que c'est un art
d'exécution
la seule chose mais le cas pas de
problème pour jouer sans wii est en tout
cas bien sûr parce que ça n'a pas
commencé
simplement on est instruit compris
d'ailleurs avec le vaccin contre la
grippe ou on a eu pendant des semaines
et des semaines une rupture des stocks
donc tout ça laisse mal présager et
c'est pas du tout la même ampleur en
termes d'opérations
moi je vais vous dire je suis contre
depuis le départ l'obligation avec un
nouveau vaccin on ne peut pas obliger
les gens oui ne serait ce que parce que
quelle contrainte quelles sanctions
éventuellement je pense le mexique a
fermé la porte à double tour et parce
que le livre soit obligatoire c'est la
raison pour laquelle je dis que je n'ai
rien à dire si ce n'est que je pense moi
que par exemple pour ce qui concerne les
ai pas je ne me contenterai pas du
personnel soignant fragile je ferais
l'ensemble du personnel soignant
parce que quand on a une communauté
humaine je pense qu'il faut la faire une
question de pédagogie aussi je me lance
par exemple si demain pour les ehpad le
gouvernement ne met pas dans le coup les
départements qui sont responsables de
ces maisons de retraite
là aussi ça risque de ce mal passé et
enfin et enfin je pense que comme c'est
une affaire de logistique je pense qu'on
devrait recourir beaucoup plus au privé
on l'a vu dans la sphère des mavs ont
c'est le privé qui a été capable de
chercher en chine des masses c'est
certainement pas la puissance publique
la bureaucratie française les assureurs
sont mis sous pression très forte de
mercier et bruno le maire qui veut
équivalent efforts beaucoup plus
importants de leur part c'est du reste
un amendement qui est
venue d'un sénateur jean-françois ils
sont est ce que vous dites les assureurs
ils ont vraiment ils ont cherché à se
défiler
ils n'ont pas joué le jeu en fait comme
tout le monde a joué un peu le jeu dans
le cadre de cette épidémie de cette
crise sanitaire
jean françois husson et pas n'importe
quel sénateurs puisqu'il est rapporteur
général et il a eu raison de déposer cet
amendement nous en avions déjà déposé au
moment du premier confinement il ya ya
ya deux points si vous voulez c'est que
il ya une rente de situation
on estime que sur le 1er semestre 1er
semestre après 1,2 milliard parce qu'il
ya eu moins de sinistres d'une part et
malheureusement ces dernières semaines
nous avons été alertés par des pme que
selon lesquelles des primes d'assurance
en tout cas les causes seront augmentés
augmenterait parfois de 20 à 30%
nous avons trouvé cette augmentation
terrible or deux sujets et nous avons
indiqué lors de nouveautés il faut une
contribution pour narguer adatia
nullement quand il ya une rente de
situation à situation exceptionnelle il
faut une contribution exceptionnelle
simplement simplement cet amendement est
une sorte d' amendement d'appel
moi je préfère plutôt que des taxes les
tours de table et le consentement des
assureurs
donc moi je les appelle aujourd'hui les
assurés à bruno retailleau pour
expliquer leur point de vue ils disent 1
l'augmentation et les classiques de ce
risque la cause 19 n'est pas
mutualisables comme ils touchent
l'ensemble des français l'ensemble des
professionnels on peut pas partager le
risque d'être et leurs arguments des
tribunaux ont condamné des assurances
parce que le restaurateur avait souscrit
à une assurance par exemple père
d'exploitation créé au moment où il a
fallu qu'assurance paye elle n'a pas
payé et ça ça n'est pas tenable et ça
n'est pas justifié bruno retailleau
puisqu'on parle on commence à parler un
peu d'économies j'ai une question pour
vous
vous dites vous disiez tout à l'heure il
faut créer de nouvelles brigades de
police pour taper les black blocks vous
êtes d'accord pour dire que d'en face à
cette pandémie on a plus que jamais
besoin de nos hôpitaux publics
j'en passe vous parliez aussi de justice
dont il faut renforcer les moyens vous
étiez le coordinateur de la campagne de
françois fillon et vous promettiez à
l'époque aux français la suppression de
500 mille fonctionnaires 500 milles sur
le quinquennat si votre candidat avait
gagné avez vous changé
avez vous changé d'avis j'ai pas changé
d'avis simplement les conditions sont
plus du tout les mêmes
mais le point fondamental est le suivant
on voit bien en france que la question
de l'efficacité de l'état
c'est pas la question des moyens parce
que si c'était vraiment le cas vous
serions en france nous qui avons la
dépense publique mondiale la plus élevée
nous serions à l'avant-garde de la
prospérité et du bonheur or ça n'est pas
le cas deux exemples pourquoi est-ce que
nous sommes là des pays à mettre le plus
d'argent dans la santé alors que nous
sommes au quatrième ou cinquième rang
pour la mortalité pour le coc vite
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
un des pays à mettre le plus d'argent
dans l'éducation alors que les
classements internationaux nous relègue
au delà de la 20e place monde vous dit
faire mieux vieillir mais bien sûr
regardez par exemple l'hôpital parce que
je vais très concret la différence entre
l'allemagne et la france c'est que
l'allemagne 25 % de personnels qui sont
des personnels administratifs en france
presque 34 %
la différence c'est plus de 120 mille
emplois donc vous voyez bien que cette
bureaucratisation aujourd'hui à créer un
état qui est un état obèse qui est
vorace parce que il dévore la richesse
cette année ce sera pratiquement 60 3%
de la richesse produite par les français
s'en rendre si j'ose dire les services
qu'on est en droit d'attendre
c'est cela que je conteste formellement
et je pense qu'on peut faire mieux
souvent avec moins jusqu'en 2022 faire
campagne en disant moins de
fonctionnaires dans la dans les noms de
postes qu vide je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire d'abord une chose il ya très
peu de temps une grande inspection
générale a montré que pratiquement 280
dix mille fonctionnaires ne faisait pas
les 35 heures est-ce que c'est naturel
est ce que c'est normal
et puis vous me dites est ce que c'est
populaire moi je m'en fiche si j'affirme
des convictions c'est pas pour plaire
aux français si je dis des vérités c'est
parce que je parlais tout à l'heure de
la question de la sincérité la sincérité
elle sera au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle prochaine
et jamais on ne me fera dire une
conviction l'un vertes une conviction
que je n'ai pas tout simplement je ne
suis pas bon je ne suis pas bon je
n'arrive pas à soutenir des choses dans
lesquelles je ne crois pas profondément
moi j'aime mon pays et je veux le
meilleur pour mon pays et si on continue
c'est les les hommes politiques
forcément plus on dépense d'argent
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est génial et
un gène qui c'est génial
l'argent des français est une question
là-dessus vêtir le quoi qu'il en coûte
et les conséquences du quoi qu'il en
coûte
c'est le mur de la dette énorme qui va
dresser devant nous enfin qui est déjà
l'un sur le prochain présence d'un
public la prochaine présents dans le
public c'est clair on espère que la
crise du coc vide sera derrière nous il
va avoir à prendre des décisions elle va
avoir à prendre des décisions pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'on fait cette dette
est ce que quelle est la position de la
droite on vous entend peu là dessus de
vous et éventuellement un bono bataillon
sur l'effacement de cette date et ce
qu'il faut l'effacer comme dit jean luc
mélenchon ou d'autres ou est ce qu'il
faut le rembourser par des hausses
d'impôts des suppressions de
fonctionnaires et quelle est votre
position rapidement très rapidement
bien sûr que non on peut pas effacer la
dette et les deux tenues en france
notamment par des mains étrangères donc
majoritairement très majoritairement si
on dit on ne remboursera pas la dette ce
sera la crise et vous verra les taux
d'intérêt augmenteront et ce sera la
catastrophe on ruine rannou retraités
nous épargnant et les français faudra la
rembourser comment en revanche en
revanche je suis opposé à ce que a
sous-entendu lors de notre déjeuner et
mal macron mercredi c'est un point qui
n'est pas sorti dans la presse je le dis
il nous a parlé de cette tentation de
faire qu'on a fait pour la sécurité
sociale de cantonner la dette coville on
voit bien ce que ça donnerait pour la
sécurité sociale vous compte n'est
ensuite pas vous créer un impôt ouais et
puis ben voilà on est toujours dans le
cantonnement ça devait s'arrêter à 2024
on a repoussé à 2030
non moi je pense que c'est la croissance
évidemment c'est la croissance cale
alan est lorsque l'économie c'est une
dynamique en revanche si on veut la
croissance ça veut dire qu'il faut créer
des richesses parce que c'est
l'appauvrissement du peuple français
sinon comment crée-t-on de la richesse
par une économie de l'offre avec un choc
d'investissement je suis pour - la
feuille de paye j'ai proposé d'ailleurs
37 heures et demie mais notamment pour
les petits salaires avec un 13e mois
sans bien sûr comment dirais-je
brutaliser la compétitivité des
entreprises en faisant en sorte qu'on
désocialise défiscalise les heures
supplémentaires
deux heures et demie de plus par semaine
ça veut dire dans une année en
l'analysant ça veut dire aussi un
certain nombre de points notamment pour
les pme les étés en essayant de
fusionner les mécanismes de
participation et d'intéressement bref je
pense que on peut parfaitement avec de
l'investissement et avec ce choc qui
concerne la revalorisation du travail se
tirer d'affaires bruno retailleau
vous avez envoyé des signaux sur une
éventuelle candidature à l'élection
présidentielle en 2022 vous reconnaissez
son courrier il aida tête du 3 novembre
saint malo du bois c'est vous qui l'avez
écrit il est dans sa salle et où
j'habite saint leu leu du primat j'y
suis j'y habite
il commence par mes chers compatriotes
pour la france désormais c'est l'heure
des choix
il ya une nana fort sûr nous pouvons
remettre de l'ordre
certains nombres de en fait c'est une
lettre programme quoi bruno retailleau
vous parlez de sincérité vous avez dit
ce sera le mot d'ordre soyez sincère est
ce que vous êtes candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
dans cette lettre il écrit parce que
j'estime que aujourd'hui la france
traverse un moment extrêmement difficile
sage en temps et ce n'est pas tant
attendu en actionnant le rôle de chaque
homme politique est d'essayer
précisément de relever l'horizon c'est
ce que j'ai tenté de venir en axant
cette lettre sur une remise en ordre
puisque aujourd'hui ce qui caractérise
vous nous l'avez dit là nous l'avait dit
qu'on s'est justement le désordre par la
question mais ne fait pas ne faites pas
votre homme politique classique bruno
retailleau
elle vous candidat à l'élection
présidentielle pourquoi est ce que ce
serait si compliqué de dire parce que
parce que les françaises sont je veux
dire dans une période difficile et qui
personne ne pense à la présidentielle ce
qu'il y a pas aujourd'hui ça pour nos
retranchements
dites-moi si les français vraiment pense
à 2022 ils voient les images ils ont vu
ce week-end ils voient la crise
sanitaire il voit le mur de les
faillites le chômage qui vont se
développer dans les prochains mois et il
faudra leur part les deux boutiques
politicienne je pense que la csrs nos
concitoyens je veux savoir qui mais pas
les convictions et je n'y porte donc
vous n'êtes pas candidat alors j'ai
voulu porter ses convictions et je me
bats d'ailleurs dans ma propre famille
politique pour que on arrive à définir
un mode de selecta alors justement
personne n'écrase match alors justement
cet exo justement justement que répondez
vous à ceux qui disent bruno retailleau
vous n'y pensez pas il ne sera pas en
capacité de rassembler peu importe ce
que je dis à ma propre famille politique
c'est que on ne peut pas se satisfaire
les français d'ailleurs le rejette du
face-à-face répétées du bis repetita
emmanuel grondin côté et marine le pen
de l'autre ça ça n'est pas possible et
je dis à ma famille politique
donnons la parole à nos militants
donnons la parole à ceux qui votent pour
nous voilà parce que ce sera la
meilleure chose pour faire le meilleur
moyen pour faire vivre le débat le débat
d idées le débat du projet vous
présentera ce suffrage pour le coup pour
faire valoir vos idées mais pourquoi pas
si si si évidemment selena et moi je
l'appelle je l'appelle ce qui justement
puisque personne n'écrase le match pour
reprendre votre expression
est-ce qu'il faut une primaire et le
primaire au sens large
organisée peut être par les républicains
mais au sens large de la droite bien sûr
moi je pense qu'il faut donner la parole
aux gens je pense qu'on peut pas parler
de démocratie représentative
on voit bien tous on se plaint de la
participation et nous on ne voudrait pas
donner cette participation de la parole
donc pas nos militants mais aussi à des
sympathisants
il faut une primaire qui soit aussi
ouverte pour donner un élan ensuite
parce que ce sera une élection difficile
et que si on n'a pas cet élan si on ne
mobilise pas notre électorat nos
sympathisants nos militants voilà bien
je pense que on perd à l'élection
présidentielle d'accord qu'est-ce que
vous mais qu'est ce que vous diriez
bruno retailleau à l'électeur de droite
en fait pourquoi est-ce que cet électeur
de droite il voterait retailleau plutôt
que macron en tout cas je sais pourquoi
ils votent
mails macron et le mal mais le maquereau
c'est une contrefaçon
des idées de la droite il fait du faux
semblant est ce que la politique pénale
des mails macro est une politique de
droite
non ça consiste à faire le minimum de
places de prison et à libérer des
détenus jamais ya eu autant de
délinquance de désordre dans la rue
est-ce que est belle ma qu'on fait une
politique migratoire de droite non on va
traiter de l'islamisme du terrorisme et
il n'ose même pas parler de
l'immigration la france aujourd'hui est
le pays qui a ouvert le plus c'est valls
est le pays qui malheureusement par
rapport aux pays d'europe et par exemple
notre vivier pays pour le rebond des
déboutés durement rapidement s'il vous
plaît justement chez nos confrères du
parisien ce matin et un grand entretien
du général pierre de villiers que vous
connaissez bien par ailleurs très bien
est ce qu'il serait temps bon candidat
pour la droite c'est quelqu'un de très
bien d'abord pierre de villiers et je
pense qu'il faut le croire sur parole
c'est un homme alors lui c'est un homme
sincère lui c'est un homme sincère et
quand il dit quand il répète que sa
trajectoire ça n'est pas l'élection
présidentielle je crois que c'est un
homme qui est animé d'un amour profond
de son pays
il est profondément patriote il voit
bien que le pays est en train de
dégringoler et il veut contribuer
justement à une forme de renaissance
il y contribuera je ne pense pas que ils
veulent y contribuer en se présentant à
l'élection présidentielle encore une
fois il le dit lui même ça n'est pas moi
qui le dis on va terminer cette émission
avec des questions un peu plus personnel
honoraires
[Musique]
bon évidemment dans un contexte
particulier mais quel est le dernier
film que vous avez vu le dernier film
qui m'a vraiment marqué c'est celui de
terrence malick
une vie cachée qui raconte cette
histoire incroyable de cet autrichien
qui résiste à hitler qui résiste aux
nazis dernier album que vous avez
téléchargés vous avez acheté cet e-mail
bah oui on a eu beaucoup de musique
classique sur ce plateau jusqu'à
maintenant est ce que vous avez un livre
à nous conseiller
j'ai plusieurs livres à vous conseiller
régis debray d'un siècle à l'autre
il ya aussi mona ozouf que j'adore qui
écrit sur george eliot / bages un gros
lecteur donc je peux vous en conseiller
pas mal de livres
les screen destination qui vous fait
rêver un voyage cause est absolument
envie de faire la france ne va bien je
suis pas un grand voyageur
j'adore je considère non je considère
qu' on a beaucoup de choses en france et
je voyagerai en revanche j'irai au liban
en début d'année parce que je pense que
là aussi il se passe des choses et qu'on
a un lien très particulier
je me préoccupe beaucoup de l'arménie je
pense que j'irai aussi en arménie parce
que c'est ce qui est en train de faire
monsieur erdogan abadou concerne
directement cette expansion de
l'islamisme et on a vu ce qui se passait
au karabakh
mais pour le reste les paysages français
c'est ce qu'on porte à l'intérieur de
soi les plus beaux paysages de deux
questions pour terminer vous avez quoi
de plus précieux qu'est ce que vous
possédez de plus précieux possèdent non
ce que j'ai de plus précieux c'est ma
famille c'est mon épouse et mes enfants
et enfin où serez vous dans deux ans un
orteil en sommes écoutés je ne peux pas
vous le dire
la vie passe vite j'espère que je serai
toujours vivant et que je neutre après
pas la cofidis il a déjà merci bruno
retailleau d'avoir été notre invité ce
midi dans bfm politique merci beaucoup
et de vie je la vide on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine
affaire suivante à suivre justement
dominique rizet fils bodin moi je
retrouve à 18h pour bfm tv sd mais
invité ce soir laurent berger secrétaire
général de la cfdt et karine lacombe
professeur de médecine à tout à l'heure